your producer for faith has been with
you for how long seven years is that the
one eight for a producer to stay that's
pretty committed yeah yeah I think so I
mean I think for the life of a producer
you know it's it's different than being
a director in that they've got to have
so many balls in the air you know they
can have 15 projects all in various
states and only a couple of them are
gonna go you know and so for for him I
mean I think that the you know the the
first couple years is just about
rewriting it and then trying to get some
awareness for the script and then from
that trying to find cast and raise money
I mean but that's a couple years process
oh well it's funny I just saw Brian I
don't know couple months ago for 80-yard
and he was talking about a small project
I know small project he's trying to do
but he's like yeah four years
it'll take four years to get all the
money together or whatever it's just did
is not that much money this is I'm gonna
be a downer this is not this much and
that much money out in the in the
independent film space you know
especially for indie dramas which is
what Mike produces and what I'm
interested in making these kind of art
already dramas and so it's you're you're
competing with a lot of people for a
very little very very little pie piece
of the pie and so it just it takes time
but yeah he held on
he held on you really believed in the
project so I'm I'm very grateful to him
for that you know and and because of his
name because he's known I mean you know
junebug anything at the time was the
lowest budget movie never get nominated
for an Oscar because Amy Adams got
nominated
for that movie you know and his films
were played everywhere Venice Sundance
Toronto and they've been nominated for
Independent Spirit Awards and all that
sort of stuff so his name being attached
to the project it's like that that was
very valuable going forward so yeah do
you share with your students the process
and how long it took oh yeah are they
surprised yeah no I'm they know me for
being a realist like there's there's no
like there's no like stars in our eyes
kind of kid kind of thing it's like all
right kids this is the reality this was
10 years and it was still hard to raise
the money and I mean and I talked some
of the some of the stuff we were talking
about in terms of numbers you know I was
talking to them about like the films
that for instance that played Sundance
that are gonna be made for they were
made for anywhere from a million to five
million dollars and they're mostly
getting if they get an offer lots of
them don't even get offers with ever get
an offer they're 100 to 150 thousand
dollars for for worldwide rights you
know and so it just to be I'm trying to
be very realistic with them so they
understand but if you really want to do
it you'll still do it it did that's I'm
a very practical guy and so one of the
things we talked about quite a bit the
way I've set my life up is I have this
one thing that pays my bills so I can do
this other thing
and so if you can figure out a way it
doesn't have to be teaching and matter
of fact I wouldn't recommend it's
teaching because there's fewer and fewer
of these jobs out there but if you can
figure out a thing that you don't hate
you don't have to love it but you don't
hate it and it pays well enough to where
you know you can pay your bills pay your
rent pay your mortgage whatever if you
have kids they get you new shoes on
their feet and then you can sort of
carve out time to do this other thing
whether it's directing your own features
or it's shooting you know you want to be
lots of students gonna be DP I would say
that's probably more popular than even
direct
I like the gear they like the camera
they want to they want to play with the
play with the tools the toys that's kind
of what I talked to them about is facing
that reality because how many kids are
in film school all around the country
are all around the world who all want to
do the same thing and so you got to
figure out how you're gonna survive
first and then you can sort of navigate
your way and that whatever you whatever
Avenue you want to go whether it's
writing directing screenwriting DP and
editing whatever do a lot of the
students say well so-and-so put their
first movie on a credit card or whatever
so they know what other schools they
probably do here it's not a thing I mean
yeah like well we I come out of the
generation of you know Kevin Smith like
Kevin Smith this thing with clerks and
it's all credit cards and and then his
career sort of blows up so there were a
lot I never did that but there were a
lot of people of my generation who did
do that you know and - not as much
success as theirs had a lot of debt and
not a huge blossoming career so no they
died don't hear that much I mean I will
say that I give them the the like if I
was a film student now what I'm what I
would probably do is I would I don't
know if I would form a company but you
know find two other people who were
different than me so if I'm the writer
director I'd find somebody who's really
good with the camera and maybe somebody
who's good at post or somebody who's
good as a kind of producer he doesn't
mind calling people out of the blue and
asking for stuff for free it's somebody
like that and the form our own little
group or whatever and decide you know we
want to do three to five things over the
next year to two years whether they be
three short films or a short film in two
commercials or some music videos or
whatever and figure out how much that's
gonna cost
when how much I shouldn't say how much
it gonna cost how much can you put
together so can all three of you save
100 bucks a month so if all three of you
were saving 100 bucks a month now all of
a sudden you got about almost four
thousand dollars you get about thirty
six hundred dollars of each one of you
puts together how to puts puts away a
hundred bucks a month and can all three
of you put a thousand dollars on a
credit card thousand dollars in debt
it's not horrible so if they all three
of them could put a thousand dollars in
credit card without killing themselves
now all of a sudden you got almost
$7,000 then can all three of you start a
crowdfunding campaign where you raise
$2,500
so with that you got about 10 grand
there close to it what can you do for
$10,000 you know the three of you can
you guys come up with again three ideas
five ideas all of them have to be small
I would not recommend that they make a
feature film I know those people who
make feature films for $10,000 maybe if
it's your third or fourth movie I would
not do it for my first but some people
could do I'm not I can I cannot do it I
could not make anything is any good for
$10,000 feature film for $10,000 I don't
what khloe's how did with the writer for
$50,000 to me is amazing did you see the
writer no I wanted to beautiful movie
it's all the trailers 50 though it's
unbelievable but so anyway that like
that is a plan where they're not going
hugely in depth there's a little bit of
debt and if they can't do the death and
they don't do the debt you just do the
savings and the crowdfunding and then
you got 6 grand or something like that
right okay what can we do for $6,000 and
it allows them to make stuff they don't
need anybody's permission it's just the
three of them or the four of them
they're doing this stuff that they're
interested in they're getting better at
it and maybe one of those things gets
them a little attention to do something
bigger probably not a film for Marvel
but maybe a local commercial for
somebody who has a little bigger budget
and they can do something more or a
bigger music video
a bigger short film or whatever some
sort of branded content for something
that would be the process that I would
go through if I was a student now coming
out and I this is by the way none of
this is and there are people who were
doing this all over the place now so I'm
not this is not some panted patted in
hat I have no patent on this patent idea
but it's a smart way to go about it
without wait because what most of us do
when we get out of film school is we all
right I'm just gonna wait for somebody
to call me and offer me all kinds of
money to do something and that never
happens
Alexander Payne is like the only person
I know that that happened for does
everybody loved his graduate thesis film
you